hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the fourth
wall now I don't know what's up with
that dangly thing up there uh is there
something that I should know about about
that wormy doodad but whatever anyway
this is a game that I found I'm a while
ago but I only got around to playing
here just now it is a dollar on the
website but there's also a demo that you
can play I bought the dog i shelled out
of the cash necessary to play this so
you play as you basically this whoa
hello excuse me pardon I I saw that and
now I hear a breathe you do dad hang on
let me something's messing with me okay
this game is designed to oh hello there
you are
I saw you now huh I feel like a cat
chasing a laser pointer like hi hey
highway young how are you slightly
concerned about that breathing but yes
this is a horror game a horror game
apparently I'm supposed to go this way
wow that is some trippy floor down there
but hang on okay I can't jump as far as
I know the only controls for WASD and
energy interact with objects but I'm
gonna follow this arrow and not worry
about the little soccer ball that's
trying to get me I said excuse me pardon
me what you see wait a minute
whoa what
oh honey right it's awfully descriptive
man I could tell that the budget was
just astronomical in this level Oh will
will what will Wheaton we can okay I
don't want to scream directly into the
mic that goes off into blackness and I
get this hi oh hi hey buddy wait where'd
you go I got this high pitch Oh die will
die Wil Wheaton will die that's awfully
that's awfully mean will you die um yes
whoa whoa hey
was this a party that I was in a bow
okay let me just have
your question quick quick quick question
do you see me what are you looking at
whoa hello
wait a minute what what and I know what
is that is it getting closer or am I
getting closer to it which way is up and
which way is down what is that what's
going on oh I am moving towards it okay
okay sister GU whoa hey now what oh oh
no it's my body I guess I am my brain
isn't I was that oh oh yeah oh oh that's
that's disgusting
I don't know even know why but it's
really really gross really gross oh oh
this is disturbing on many levels okay
I'm just gonna go I got one impact
crater I don't need anything else I want
to go back this way the way I came
hopefully you won't oh oh it's so gross
oh it's grody I'm gonna go this way
again something is going wrong in this
world here no no fine you know what Al
Gore go towards the weird dangly worm
that's bleeding out of its anus okay
what's the point what's with the dignity
what's with this high-pitched beeping
what's with the walls I know this game
is called fourth wall but maybe some
guidance would be lovely is that
supposed to guide me somehow
oh hello data key okay my enter button
isn't working
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what I'm supposed to do
did I lose did our one don't know what I
don't know what yeah okay Vladdy the
blood gotta catch it
oh this is so wrong
oh it's so wrong ah ah that's that yeah
okay now why wait a minute what hey wait
a minute
you you you way to go that's all that
whoa what happened that's all
what huh something kachunk you come back
here time out here you little tray what
was it you aha what'd you do what'd you
do come back
whoa what oh no
oh hey hey hey oh oh you come back here
now you come back here you see don't
make me unleash the prospector on you Oh
will and you won't like it yeah
I'm Hershel okay sir I apologize
everyone knows ed my Hershel is the
prospector hey come back here no don't
run away from me wait a minute just
gonna go into figure eight and I need to
catch it again um yeah yeah that's right
yeah over here ain't gonna chase you I'm
gonna be whoa what why what what did it
happen did it detonate in an atomic
explosion what is this what is this Oh
what is that what did I just do I'm
Logan
yeah this game is weird what is that oh
my god is that a face I didn't even
realize what that was
oh oh you creepy suddenly you got very
creepy okay intercept intercept
trajectory intercept trajectory
intercept yeah Oh
mayhaps I was not supposed to what oh I
died again that is that's a lot more
blood oh oh it sounds like it's in pain
good good
what am I supposed to do now what am I
supposed to do now
do I need to find another Lyndsey was
these dots you you whoa what wow wow wow
Oh Oh I done goofed Oh
why don't you where am I Oh
again state this is gonna wreak a bit on
mutt havoc on my encoding
oh hi did I get it I did it I did it I
don't know what I did but I did it I
don't know what I did but um but um but
um but um but um it's bigger on the
inside than it is on the outside what uh
so far I haven't been scared so much as
I've been weirded out under this scare
is gonna what oh oh oh oh hi there
how you doing what oh you do you all use
on poor babies don't look so good
almost wrong would error in zero
condition win at line 22 escaped reload
okay
yeah I'm sure this is gonna be normal
pardon
whoa
you seem that what you seem to have some
you seem to have a few issues what when
I can fly why can't I fly uh okay now I
think the game is taking a turn for the
disturbing oh wait it started out as
that okay so I'm going up to see where
this worm starts at maybe I should maybe
I shouldn't weird disturbing oh I've
reached the ceiling okay that that worm
is getting steadily more colorful what
it means it's starting to bleed whoa you
stop that now that comes out of nowhere
that's hardly fair a fourth
well oh I thought that might a bit work
I can move ah
you
hang on a second everybody hang on a
second I gotta do something apparently
what the hell hang on a second everybody
hold your horses
cuz this just took a trip into the
disturbing I've already said that but
you know what I mean okay
okay
okay there's a thing down here that says
click and those a shadowy figure I
wasn't recording full screen out
recording just a game and I shoulda
known okay
clicking clicking I clicked on it oh hi
what even what where'd you go
what happened with that
what happened I guess it it
Hey
you
you'll know it's there now
one
you
you you can go now you can go you may
leave
you there's nothing else here it's all
gone it's all done so you can you may
you may leave you may leave
you
this is what I do this when I'm not
recording I sit at my desk and do
nothing
disabuse to go we should do something
important
you
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go gonna go run
an errand
okay
okay goal
gonna go bareback or not I don't know
don't know how long it's gonna take so
um you can go at any time
you can go anywhere I'm not keeping you
here stop I'm gonna go
and I go you stay classy
let me go
you
hmm Marc Valvo
hey he was that here I don't know what
happened
whoa when you Ryan please lower bar
everyone
tire blows Gavin you bastard I don't
blink
oh wait